sf offiziell wahlkampf das duell merkel
gegen schuld ist
deswegen hatte ich mich ja auch nur
wahnsinnig gefreut auf den politischen
aschermittwoch diese woche aber dann
sagen aber beide haben teilgenommen
helmut maier so hart sagen vor allem die
kanzlerin die ist halt einfach nicht
gemacht fürs birkfeld für die direkte
begegnung mit diesen menschen achten sie
im folgenden mal auf ihren besonders
euphorischen gesichtsausdruck
[Musik]
wer liebt solche veranstaltung ja merkel
in meck-pomm ddr - karneval mehr
stimmung geht nicht freunde
hauptsache hauptsache keiner erwähnt die
flüchtlingskrise der schuld wird dann am
ende platz ich sage dir wir schaffen das
[Applaus]
[Musik]
man kann der kapelle keinen vorwurf
machen da war kein geld da der
politische aschermittwoch ist natürlich
das wissen sie ursprünglich eine
bayerische idee ist die einzige
bayerische idee die jemals funktioniert
hat haben sie das geile plakat gesehen
mit dem könig hofft und co zu ihrem
aschermittwoch booms eingeladen haben
hier haben viele gesagt typisch
frauenfeindliche csu ilse aigner darf
nicht mit auf foto aber das stimmt gar
nicht gesteht noch etwas weiter rechts
und macht die schlüssel für eine gute
frage
den schülern durchaus retuschiert die
unter stalin so wieder der ball
aber jetzt mal zu den attacken auf den
politischen gegner auf martin schulz
dem hat der seehofer ab 1 ein geschenk
wem hatte ein geschenk voll auf die
zwölf aber wenn er mit dieser politik
fortführt mannheim künftig in bayern der
martinschule nicht mehr marken schuld
ein schummler ist der martin der
flugplatz gerne ja das war hat schimmel
schulz fordert dabei weiter korrekturen
an der agenda 2010
jetzt könnte man einwenden dass die spd
von den letzten 19 jahren 15 mitregiert
hat und so gewinnt theoretisch und zeit
gab es korrigieren aber hauptsache
soziale wärme gemeinsam und so gemeinsam
ich komme auf dieses woche zurück wenn
wir gemeinsam die ideen entwickelt wenn
wir gemeinsam dafür werben gemeinsam als
partei so gemeinsam mit den
gewerkschaften wir wollen etwas schaffen
und zwar gemeinsam dann sind wir
gemeinsam stark gemeinsam das sind wir
alle hier und zwar gemeinsam
ich wiederhole das noch mal das ist im
prinzip klar geworden